Jimmy thank how you doing my friend
good luck off welcome thanks for having
me no problem for people who don't know
what is your role here at gamespy so I'm
GameSpot you know somewhat new I guess
tell you editor I've been here about a
month or so covering lots of hardware
yeah you been covering hardware for a
long time right yeah I've been covering
like PC gaming and hardware for close to
10 years now Brian a lot of stuff has
changed and a lot of stuff hasn't
changed you're still playing graphics
cards in - yes motherboards and seen a
good awesome well there has been a bunch
of interesting graphics cards called my
house in the past week at the 1078 nad
vote of which you have reviewed and the
section title I have for this originated
was should we all bite a 10-7 because I
can't like in recent memory I can't
think of a you know a series of cards
that have comment that have really sort
of jumped ahead
is it like it reminds me of the sort of
like the 3dfx days almost when you're
like oh this is such like a massive jump
in terms of quality to cost that you
sort of like have to jump on it yeah so
the 1080 both the 1080 and 1070
they're both Nvidia Pascal cards and
usually so this jump from the 1080 from
like the 980 and the 1070 from the you
know 970 it represents yeah arguably the
hugest jump that I've seen in in recent
history in terms of performance and I
think it's because a combination of
different things but normally you get a
faster you know video card because of
architecture improvements or like a
different more efficient nanometer
design like a smaller nanometer design
both of these cards have been able to
enjoy both right so it's both a you know
sort of a shrinking processor design and
also a new and more efficient
architecture so where did this impetus
come from is this like because you know
me as a layman - somebody who buys
graphics cards but I don't really know
I'm thinking like is this something to
do with like 4k or VR like where is the
like push me this amount of you know
improve so who's this for
yeah so I would say the 1080 in 1070 so
1080 is about 12 to 23 percent faster
okay it's also like 36 percent more
expensive so 1070 and
than the tenth in 70 so 10th time he's
actually a better deal even though both
cards are actually really good deals
yeah 1070 is only like 300 80 bucks for
some 3 or 80 bucks and it performs as
well if not better than the Titan X
which is $1000 that it actually
outperforms it by like up to 9% for my
tests and then it's like 55 percent
cheaper Wow
so that's pretty crazy yeah but as to
answer your question about as to who
it's for I would say if you have a 1080p
monitor like you know and you plan on
sticking with 1080p this is these cards
are probably not for you right they make
a lot more sense when it comes to like
1440p or UHD as people call it yeah the
1080 can also do 4k as well although you
probably won't be able to you know max
out every single game you know with
playable framerates it can do most of
them I'd say so what games did you test
it on because I the review obviously I
tested it on a bunch of things I you
know ran it through about half a dozen
benchmarks or so Metro last light which
is you know multi graphics cards yeah
you know shadow of mordor and things
like that but I also played some more
recent games so I played like overwatch
I played you know the PC version rise of
the Tomb Raider dirt three The Witcher 3
and yeah like at 1080p like it's gonna
be able to you know max out they have
above 60
except for Tomb Raider which is
problematic for some reasons all that
hair tech maybe it's not the best port I
don't know but aside from rise of the
Tomb Raider it will be able to max at
you know every game way above 60 and
your monitor to most people's monitor
can only like you know they they mostly
have a refresh rate of 60 Hertz right so
which means that you're wasting
basically money or frames
you wanna want to hit goes beyond that
and so if you have a 1440p monitor or
really high refresh rate 1080p monitor
that goes up to 120 hertz hundred sixty
five Hertz or whatever then it makes
sense so that sounds like the catch to
me man now I know why it's cheap because
the universe is gonna need me to buy a
4k monitor to get the most of this or at
least the 1440p one right yeah yeah it's
crazy stuff so let's to me like it seems
like you know I am very much the type of
person I think a lot of people are who
like they don't go for the top top top
end across her scarred I go for like the
high end of the medium or like the low
end of the top and the 1070 seems like a
great deal a 380
so why would I want the 1080 I would say
I would say get Ted's M&E but there is a
use case for a 1080 like I said it is
thing at 12 the 23% faster but it is for
the enthusiast that like wants the best
the best right now it is the best single
video card right now for VR for 4k for
anything right but if I mean you can
save a lot more money and get similar
levels of performance you know by going
with the 1070 but I think NVIDIA knows
that people are willing to buy something
like the 10 80s yeah that's why it
exists how does it perform that in terms
of the Titan X with like stuff like
virtual reality like is there the 1080
is ridiculously good at VR it's
single-handedly the best VR video card
the 1070 is the second best video it's
like I think I think compared to I'd
have to look at the charts but I think
even maybe the 1080 compared to the 980
which is actually above the recommended
specs I think the recommended specs is
like a 970 m so the 980 is even better
than that and then 1080 is like 65%
faster than the 980 Wow at NBR according
to like Valve's VR benchmark anyways and
how much is the 1080 at the moment the
1080 starts at 599 okay so it's not even
then it's like so much cheaper than
getting it so even then it's like so
it's it's about 600 bucks but it's way
faster than then $1000 video card yeah
so even that's like a stupid deal and
then the 1070 is like way it's even
faster than the 10x as well and it cost
like 55 percent less like that's insane
yeah so sine X is basically like a nun
by a bull of cards basically so I think
if you bought a Titan X like a month ago
you're probably crying right oh god I've
actually looked at Amazon already and it
looks like the 10-7 news in the 10 80s
are are already sort of dropping in
right so I asked in video about this in
the industry there's something called
the soft launch and that's when you know
a company like Nvidia will announce a
new video card and Margot's will lift
and will be able to review it but it'll
be a paper launch in that there aren't
that many cards to buy and so I asked if
I asked Nvidia if this is a paper launch
they said no we actually have units it's
just in the first week or so a couple
weeks you know
gonna be sold out okay so you'll be able
to get them and she'll either after so I
guess the last question about this and
this is the worry of anyone buying a
graphics card you just spoke about the
Titan next folk if I'm gonna buy one of
these I'm guessing like is there another
crazy graphics card revolution like six
months out where like do you think these
are going to be the sort of the mainstay
of graphics cards for the next while if
you ask me know the typical cadence is
you feel like like the 900 series for
instance Nvidia released the 99 79 16
all that stuff and it goes to cheaper
from there but they also you know
eventually announced the Titan X so we
might see the Titan series I mean this
is my conjecture I don't know anything
we might see a Titan version of the 10
series a 1000 1080 series or whatever
and then you could see you know normally
in this type of environment you'd
probably see a 1080 Ti eventually right
and if I were to guess I'd probably
suspect and this is again my conjecture
I'm guessing maybe holidays I'll get one
of those cards that the Titan version or
the ti version doesn't sound like it's
worth waiting around for them
necessarily like these are like the last
wanted lines in your review was crazy
was like when you compare it to the
Titan X it's up to 9 percent faster and
55 percent cheaper like that's a great
so first of all these are not the
end-all be-all cards in terms of
performance there's in in the PC
enthusiast space there's always room for
more performance for K running Metro
last light at 4k with everything
everything maxed out there's no single
video card that can do that ok Ryeon not
even not even to 1080 so I don't think
can do that not at 60 frames per second
anyways so there is room you know for
growth so there is you know there is a
use case scenario for getting a 1080 TI
or the Titan version I then can you run
to 1080 or 720 1080 and 1070 and SLI no
okay then you might be able to do ten
seven years like a physics chord right
but nobody really does that yeah yeah so
damn like my Hardy I'm so sorry I don't
I don't know much about anything I'm
actually in the process of building my
own the East Coast I'm just gonna get my
credit card Jimmy in my right
it's great when we have like good expert
on there you could just like ply with a
bunch of questions and he just knows
absolutely everything so yeah I'll give
you my passwords I don't want that
though cuz everybody goes to measly can
you fix my computer you're like your
aunties I'll pretend like I was smart
enough to figure it all out myself and
take credit down then I'm saying if
something breaks or then you go to mean
it's like awesome I say why not you're
upgrading your PC at the moment I feel
like I upgrade my PC I upgrade in mind
like six months too late last year like
I have not I'd completed The Witcher 3
on Xbox one which it looks so much
better on PC it's like painful and I'm
glad I have a never over watching stuff
but uh yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's
crazy how you know I have good this sort
of stuff is calm in the past year like
PC games like I was a PC gamer for like
four ten years now slowly kept into the
console space now - the dark side it's
yeah it's so cost-effective now and a
waited I don't even think it was or
maybe I'm just like not a 18 year old
scratching money to buy some cards
anymore so yeah crazy thanks thank you
so much for coming on